should be legal on the stages of
development
how many weeks is it now currently like
so um in the UK it's interesting it's up
to six months but there's kids that have
survived so it's legal up to 26 weeks I
think and there's kids that have
survived at 24.
um
honestly I guess if it's 26 weeks and
it's 26 weeks okay
what do you think
sorry which question so where do you
think abortion should um be legal at
like at what point
it has to be your choice
it has to be the choice of the person
this so if I enable in life so if I if I
you know like what human right are you
protecting you know are you protecting
the human right of the person that's
actually carrying it at what stage so so
I'm saying like if I wanted to get an
abortion I'm going to give birth in
three days
so I'm saying like I think we'd have
some common ground on like where it
should be like at least at certain
points at eight months nine months it
should be illegal so I'm saying at what
point would you mark that life is life
why
is it uh is it 24 that it is illegal or
is it 22. I know it's got 22. is 24
weeks it's 24 weeks but classified as
illegal but if there's any kind of
perceived abnormalities right up until
birth and so there's actually
um statistics I can't remember the top
of my head where you know with the Down
Syndrome or even cleft lip palette I
don't know what that is
um
yeah that's that's a perceived yeah
Beyond 24 weeks you can get so if if
someone had a clef like because that's
when your when your lip is just yeah but
they can fix that yeah yeah yeah and so
that is that in the UK and the us or
just the UK I don't know about the US
wow yeah so there's what did they base
that decision on like why have have they
why why has someone in a laboratory or
some sort of assumingly scientific field
decided that that is the age before like
giving an opinion on why and what I
think it used to be 28 and then when
because you think this it was 1967 when
the abortion act come came in and
um actually when it first came in it
didn't come in to to give you a a right
you know like it's different to America
where it was deemed a riot
um it was actually for extreme
situations and that's why what Laura
mentioned about you need to have two
doctors because there's actually to to
sign off whether they think you should
be able to have one and it's under
things like if you're if the um to
continue with the pregnancy is going to
impact your mental health or your
physical health so at what point was the
mental health lack disregarded as a it's
still there so most of the abortions
that actually happened today by the
letter of the law in this nation are
illegal or probably illegal because most
people think that we have abortion on
demand but we don't yeah they're meant
so there's all sorts of things where the
abortion clinics pre-scion forms and
stuff like that but that thing that
Laura said is very true that two doctors
are meant to sign off and give you a you
know a woman a kind of a consultation to
see whether they think that that there
is some going to be some mental issues
so what point is that like not an
acceptable reason
sorry I don't understand your question
so at what point is the psychological uh
state of a human being
become like a
so if we're I think I understand your
question but if we're pro-life it's
consistent so it doesn't matter whether
it has a risk to the person's life
carrying the life
um yeah I mean I I personally don't know
enough about those situations I would
say I could be educated more on that
stuff but I I think if
from what I understand there's like very
few situations that that actually
happens so one situation would be for
example if you had a ectopic pregnancy
yeah yeah so that's uh Fallopian tubes
yeah so the so the kind of the embryo
hasn't made it up to the to the womb to
implant and the woman implants into the
fallopian tube and that's dangerous
right it's dangerous woman and the
child's not going to survive because it
can't grow and you know and continue to
develop in the fallopian tube so what
will happen is the the baby will die and
the mother will die so what they do that
baby should be allowed to die and that
and that is life-saving so the intent of
that is to save life right so it's to
save life if we could well both lives
but I mean sorry to say save the
mother's life sorry so in that situation
you would agree that that would be yeah
and I don't it's not even considered
it's a very different procedure so they
what they do is they go in and they cut
the fallopian tube and take it out so
it's not even what is it won't be in the
abortion status it doesn't classify as
an abortion no because that's
life-saving treatment yeah so what would
you do if it was Mother versus child
like say if it like other was pregnant
and it was in the right area but they
said
um yeah I think I think the oh the the
purpose should always be to save life
where you can save life right so so if
you can't save if you can't save the
uh would you mean a mother over the
child so like if Cass is saying that
like if it was a situation where the
doctor had assumingly said to someone
that wasn't even the mother because at
this point I'm assuming she doesn't
actually have the ability to communicate
necessarily and
I can't save you and your child what do
I do what would I mean these are
hypothetical situations I mean they not
exist I know there's a there's a group
of doctors in in Ireland that that they
say that actually abortion
um I mean that ectopic pregnancy is is
something different because we're
talking about elective abortion right
where a woman goes to having a balloon
about all abortions just so in terms of
the ones to save there's a group of
doctors in Ireland and they say that
abortion is never necessary to um save a
mother they would continue to birth a
child even if the mother was to die that
I I said that they say that there's
never a situation where abortion is
necessary so for example let's take
um is it pre-eclampsia which happens
quite later on in pregnancy or there's
some things that happen Okay so so if
something happens later in pregnancy
it's a late term abortion is very is
actually very dangerous for the woman
because she now has they have to go in
they have to rip you know the baby's
limbs apart they have to crush the skull
and to and she then she has to give
birth to that um dead baby
no it's G it's it's easier to induce the
woman let her and let her give birth to
the baby this is I'm talking late term
six months on it's easier to to for her
to give birth it'll be more dangerous
for the woman to go through a late-term
abortion than it would for her to go
through with her birth so you would
carry a dead baby for the last three
months of your pregnancy or if I
misunderstood no after six months so
after six months the baby can survive
outside the womb in a um
so then they'll give birth to the baby
and put the baby Force the pregnancy
so abortion won't say that woman's life
because that's that's a two-day
procedure so there's this there's this
there's a lot of these lies that have
been going going around that are put out
by the abortion industry things like
even the stats that they said we're
going to go back to Backstreet abortions
they were conflated and it's been proven
by abortionists the the guy who came up
with those stats he's now changed and
he's now pro-life and he's yeah and the
guy
um in and you can Google it I've
forgotten his name apologies but they
said that these stats were made up
so I actually don't know what are the
back alley stats tell me about that
um I don't know this that's the actual
stats but but that's one of the
arguments you'll hear okay if we make
abortion illegal you're going to go back
to they're going to go back to back Ali
abortion okay but um the thing is we've
got these pills now and the and the
appeals the pills are just being sent by
post anyway so that in a way the
abortion industry has put it back to to
back early abortions by Distributing
these pills for people to do it I don't
even think about that in their homes
but yeah the the the stats that they
gave that all these women are going to
die if they don't get abortions they
were all um made up
and could totally the guy came forward
saying he that he made them up yeah I
think it was narrow n-a-r-a-l sorry I
don't know the guy's name okay and he he
said he made up the stats yeah they he
was part of the group and they they they
were propaganda it was propaganda why do
you think they do that because when
you're trying to the the agenda was to
you know make my body my choice right
and bring abortion in because before
abortion was legal most people weren't
for abortion right right it wouldn't be
like it is today because it wasn't
scientifically possible
they hadn't successfully done it so
there were things happen like people
would take herbs you know throughout
history there's been ways that people so
there's always been a desire so it was
possible yeah I mean there's been
there's been ways but in terms of
most of society weren't for abortion but
when you change the law how come it does
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible